[موسيقى]
عمل ايه اسوي الاثار المصغره الوقت فراغي
بوقت كورونا سويتها قلعه اربيل بوابه قلعه
اربيل جسر زاخو مناره الحدباء مناره اربيل
مناره
واستمريت يعني المواطنين جاده من ادوات
بسيطه يعني ما عندي ادوات ادواتي
والعمال هنا المخيم البسطاء يجيبون يعني
هاي شغلات الماده الفلين
وقاعده اشتغل بها
[موسيقى]
هذا البيت بيت يسمونه قوم القاسو
هذا البيت كان به يعني شوف تقريبا يمكن
انهم سته اخوان من سبع اخوات كانوا بهذا
البيت
يعني بشغلات بسيطه وهم عمل متكاتفين
ويعني عسى ما شاء الله هم يعني اكثر من
قريتين هم صاروا هذا اول ما تاسس اللي
يعني البيت ماله هو هذا البيت ابوهم الله
يرحمه
هو حتى هو البنات
جسر زاخو يسمونه يعني دلال جسر دلال ايه
هو جسر تاريخي جسر زاخو
هيا مناره سنجار الاثريه
وهاي مناره الحدباء الاثريه موصل
وهاي مناره اربيل
الاثريه
هذا بير يوسف عليه السلام
اخوانه
بالبيع هاي الطفل ريان من وقع بالبير تعرف
كل الناس عرفت فيه وسويت مجسم
فهنا بالمخيم الاطفال واحد يجيب الاخ هذا
طفل ريان نشوف شلون صار هاي الالات
[موسيقى]
يوميه يجون اكثر يعني واحد يسحب الاخ
هذا
القدس
قبه الصخره مرت الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
هاي يا سامر
هاي سامراء تاريخيه ورمز من رموز
الاثار العراقيه
هو يرمز
يعني للتضحيه للعراق
للعراقين العراقيين جميعا هو هذا نصب
الشهيد سويته
مناره الحدباء تتميز
بنقوشها
الاثريه يعني المميزه هي تقريبا اكثر من
من عشر يعني رسمات
مناره الحدباء وتجي وراها جسر زاخو
منار السنجار بس هي يعني اكثر شيء حتى
يعني اكو ناس يجون عليها هنا هاي يقول
شلون جبتها بهاي الادوات البسيطه
[موسيقى]
هاي اول ما سويتها قلعه اربيل سويتها
المواطنين هنا شجعوني وقالوا احنا شو تريد
نسوي يعني هم عمال بسطاء هم يجيبون يعني
مادات الفلين
هم يجيبون الشغلات الاريدها هم شجعوني
استمر بهاي الشغله ولا ما اكو اي امكانيه
ولا هم شجعوني واستمريت
وشويه شويه وشوفت هاي شوفتها عينك
[موسيقى]
وسويت يعني اسعى طموح ما اسوي يعني شكو
اثار
العراقيه او العربيه اسويها ان شاء الله
ولو عندي مكان اسويها كامل ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات